هذا هو ما يبدو عليه الركض للنجاة بحياتك
في
غزة، سيارة إسعاف بداخلها فتاة صغيرة
وامرأة جريحة هزتها
الانفجارات أثناء محاولتهما الفرار.
ليس من الواضح ما حدث لهما، لكنهما
من بين عشرات الآلاف من
الأشخاص في غزة  تحركت إسرائيل بعد أن
دعا الجيش الإسرائيلي ما يقرب من نصف
سكان غزة (حوالي 1.1 مليون شخص) إلى
التوجه جنوبًا في غضون ساعات، ولكن على طول
الممرات الآمنة التي حددها الجيش الإسرائيلي،
ترى الرعب المطلق، حيث ترى المذبحة
والفوضى في شارع صلاح دين، أحد أكثر الشوارع رعبًا.
طرق إخلاء محددة في
أعقاب الانفجارات التي قتلت عائلات
وسط ممتلكاتهم حددت شبكة CNN الموقع الجغرافي
لهذا الفيديو وأربعة مقاطع أخرى من
المشهد المروع.
وتصف الأمم المتحدة تحذير إسرائيل بشأن الإخلاء بأنه
مستحيل وانتهاك
لقواعد الحرب،
واتهم المسؤولون الفلسطينيون الجيش الإسرائيلي بقصف
المدنيين  حتى أثناء فرارهم،
قُتل أو جُرح العشرات من الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم في
غارات جوية إسرائيلية وفقًا لحماس، وقد
تواصلت شبكة CNN مع الجيش الإسرائيلي
للتعليق، حيث يتدفق الضحايا على
مستشفيات غزة المكتظة، ومرة ​​أخرى،
أصبح أصغرهم عالقًا في
تبادل إطلاق النار لما يقرب من نصف
سكان غزة.  هو
الأطفال، ماذا فعل الأطفال
ليستحقوا هذا، تقول هذه المرأة هل
قاتلوكم، هل أطلقوا الصواريخ، ماتت ابنة أخي
وعائلتها بأكملها،
الناجية الوحيدة هي فتاة تبلغ من العمر عامين،
نظام الرعاية الصحية على
حافة الاكتمال  الحصار يجعل من
المستحيل إدخال المساعدات إلى القطاع،
وهناك بالفعل نقص في
كل شيء حتى المساحة في
المستنقع، نحن نحتفظ بالموتى في شاحنات الآيس كريم
حتى لا تتعفن الجثث،
يقول هذا الطبيب إن غزة في أزمة، غزة بحاجة إلى
المساعدة من أجلها  أولئك الذين ما زالوا قادرين على التحرك جنوبًا،
هذا أحد الأحياء التي
من المتوقع أن تفر منها العائلات باتجاه
كين يونيس حيث تسببت الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية في حدوث فوضى،
هذه إبادة جماعية وليست حرب، إنها
إبادة جماعية كما يقول هذا الرجل، وهي
محاولة لإجبار جميع الفلسطينيين على الخروج من  إن
العثور على ملجأ في قطاع غزة أمر
خطير ومميت، وبالنسبة للعديد من
العائلات اليائسة بحثًا عن مأوى،
فإن الخوف من عدم وجود أماكن آمنة متبقية هو
عبد العزيز سي إن إن
لندن